لا هذه صور هناك الكثير من الاصوات التي
تطالب التي تاتينا الان على شاشه الجزيره
تظهر تعرض معبر بيت حانون للقصف فكان
مراسل جزيره الياس كرام قد اشار الى ذلك
قبل لحظات عن تعرض معبر بيت حنون الى
قذيفه هارون هذا ما ذكره الياس قبل قليل
هذا المعبر المقفل بالطبع تعرض اذا لقذيفه
هارون من قبل الفصائل المقاومه الياس كان
يتحدث عن ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال بانه نجح في خفض اطلاق
نسبه الهاون بنسبه 50 في المئه ولكن من
الواضح بان اطلاق وظائف الهون مستمره
ساعود مره جديده الى الياس ان كان لديه
المزيد من المعلومات عن وصول قذائف الها
ون الى معبر بيت حنون وهذا ما كنت قد اشرت
اليه الياس قبل دقائق من الان
بالفعل فدى وهنالك على الاقل يعني
كاميرات المراقبه الموجوده في هذا المعبر
تؤكد على الاقل سقوط قذيفتين في منطقه
قريبه من معبر بيت حانون ايرز الواقع الى
الشمال من قطاع غزه دون وقوع اصابات ودنى
وقوع اضرار لان القذائب جاءت في مناطق
مفتوحه ونحن كنا نشير فداء الى ان كل
المناطق القريبه من السياج الامني تتعرض
حقيقه الان الى
ضربات بقذائف الهاون والمقذوفات الصاروخيه
قصيره المدى في اطار التكتيك الذي يتبعه
نشطاء المقاومه الفلسطينيه في التعامل مع
هذه المعركه يعني هم من يحددون ايقاع هذه
الضربات فتاره يتوقفون لفترات من الراحه
ومن الهدوء وتاره يركزون ضرباتهم على
الشريط الامني على السياج الام ني واحيانا
يوسعون دائره الاستهدافات كما جرى في
الساعه الاخيره صوب العمق الاسرائيلي صوب
مدينه ازدود مرتين سددت المقاومه صواريخها
باتجاه هذه المدينه الكبيره التي يقطنها
نحو
225,000 اسرائيلي والى عشرات البلدات
الصغيره الواقعه الى الشرق منها وفيما
يعرف بالسهل الداخلي في تلك المناطق
ابقى معنا الياس